The computers we're using in this class are termed heterogeneous.
They have two different processors in them, the CPU and the GPU.
Now, if you write a plain C program, your code will only allow you to use the CPU to run your program.
So how do we write code that will run on the GPU?
That's where CUDA comes in.
The CUDA programming model allows us to program both processors with one program
so that we can use the power of the GPU in our programs.
CUDA supports numerous languages, but in this class we're using C.
Now, part of your CUDA program is plain C and it will run on your CPU.
CUDA calls this the host.
The other part of your problem will run on the GPU in parallel.
It's also written in C but with some extensions that we use to express parallelism.
The CUDA term for your GPU is the device.
Then, the CUDA compiler will compile your program, split it into pieces
that will run on the CPU and the GPU, and generate code for each.
CUDA assumes that the device, the GPU, is a co-processor to the host, the CPU.
It also assumes that both the host and the device have their own separate memories where they store data.
In the systems we use in this class, both the CPU and the GPU
have their own physical dedicated memory in the form of DRAM,
with the GPU's memory typically being a very high performance block of memory.
Now, in this relationship between CPU and GPU, the CPU is in charge.
It runs the main program, and it sends directions to the GPU to tell it what to do.
It's the part of the system that's responsible for the following.
One, moving data from the CPU's memory to the GPU's memory.
Two, moving data from the GPU back to the CPU.
Now, in the C programming language, moving data from one place to another is called Memcpy.
So, it makes sense that in CUDA, this command, either moving data from the CPU to the GPU
or moving data from the GPU to the CPU, is called cudaMemcpy.
Three, allocating memory on the GPU, and in C this command is Malloc, so in CUDA, it's cudaMalloc.
And four, invoking programs on the GPU that compute things in parallel.
These programs are called kernels.
And, here's a lot of jargon in one phrase.
We say that the host launches kernels on the device.